welcome to another episode of ask mr
wonderful and guess who i've got with me
you've met him before
teddy is an absolute author of great
work on watches i love him i love his
his depth of knowledge but you know we
talk so much about
really expensive pieces all the time so
i
decided to challenge teddy i said listen
let's both go into our collections and
come up with inexpensive pieces that are
spectacular watches
something you'd be proud to wear on your
wrist you don't have to spend a fortune
on
and i really mean it i think everybody
says oh you have to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars to build a watch
collection
not true you can get a very diverse and
beautiful set of dials
very inexpensively so let's go to teddy
well thank you for that flattering
interest well
it's true we've done some great work
together mostly on the really high-end
amazing and all kinds of brands that
cost a fortune but now it's time to go
the other direction
show me what you think is great value so
what i did was i mixed a few different
things so i had some stuff
personal launches stuff that we sell on
our site but i wanted to kind of start
from like the lower end to begin with so
i kind of call these like
gateway drug kind of water you will
mention price right yes i will mention
prices so
for all of these these are all sub 500
dollars and these are watches that
people
sub 500 500
i thought it would be fun to just see
how you would react to them so a couple
things i mean i have to ask you right
out of the gate
if you're buying watch for 500 should
you assume it's not collectible you
should assume it's not a great
investment
or should you just write it off over
time so i would not
say classified as an investment this is
just a fun piece this is just a fun one
just fun to watch
500 bucks some of these do retain their
value
reasonably well compared to other things
under 500 dollars
what you're maybe going to buy but
that's not the reason why you're getting
it you're getting just to maybe get into
this level watches for the first time
and will we know some of the brands
absolutely well so for this first range
i mean one that's probably going to be
very popular is
climax and this of course this is the
entry level of
entry level so this is 260 this is the
timex marlin so back in the 1960s you
might have been familiar with seeing
some of the marlins and
the back in the 1960s i couldn't afford
a two hundred dollar watch well that was
probably back then i mean
maybe talking 10 10 bucks you know back
then yeah so
so the club you know it's it's retro
vintage now exactly
that's beautiful so that watch has been
so popular yeah for
this newer enthusiast getting into the
hobby for the first time so 260 bucks
you got a yoda caliber inside of it
and it's it's just it's fun to put on
your wrist and say yeah it's a timex
yeah it's just fun you know like hey i'm
like
that's cool that's a good entry door so
a couple other places to look
so this is a brand that has become very
much uh an
entry door into the world of entry level
divers yeah it's orient so orient is a
japanese brand
yeah you're actually under the seiko
epson corporation yeah that is called
the cano
that one's a little bit more striking
it's got a red dial yeah that's
definitely a diver watch
yes okay around 250 to 300 are you
kidding
yes for 250 would you drown if you went
down with the tank on
no that's 200 meters water resistance
very capable
wow okay that's a surprise to me that's
a pretty good deal that's a spectacular
looking piece
for that price 260 bucks we're not
talking secondhand these are this is
brand new
brand new retail brand new factory
pricing absolutely factory warranty and
all
this is a whole new world no one knows
about teddy you've discovered here
i don't people know about it i don't
know if you know no i don't 250
it's it's no i haven't looked at too
many watches for 250 bucks
two other places to look i know you're
in love with dials yes
seiko to me okay you can't you can't go
wrong with seiko
i want you to look at this watch so this
is the srpf srpf41
this is how much i mean look at that
dial just look at it close i mean
this is not a grand cycle this is a sake
it's a seiko and that's an important
distinction to make
but the dial on that what i mean
spectacular
automatic watch automatically price
point 480 bucks
wow you're just taking my breath away
that by the way that
looks like it's worth 1200 times more
it's just i mean that dial is effect i
mean that is technically it is
they're famous for their dials it can't
be one of their hand-painted dolls for
that price
but they've emulated the look yes they
have and it's very well executed so
there's another very popular
series in this range which is called the
cocktail time so they basically
replicate
uh inspiration from like japanese
cocktails and probably the best dials
you're gonna find before
really really nice piece i mean i have
to admit that's a great deal
but i always felt always seiko you get
value you do yeah and you know i buy a
lot of grand seiko product because it's
patek
philippe quality almost you know that's
the way i look at it
at a fraction of the price seiko is i
mean people love psycho
i absolutely love psycho so i thought
that was a guy who loves dials figured
that was a good one so this is
a bulva lunar pilot you might be
thinking this kind of looks like a
species no the brand everybody does
cool backstory behind this watch so this
was a watch that actually went to the
moon as well
no way 1971 apollo 15 david scott
where is kidding and how the story goes
you're a walking encyclopedia
i don't know how much of this is fact or
fiction but apparently he had a speed
master on
yeah crystal popped off oh i heard this
story when he got off the lunar module
he brought his own personal bull the
lunar pilot so that's the cool thing
about you had it as a backup
is there any truth to that story there
is truth to that story that he actually
brought it on because it actually sold
at auction in 2015 for 1.3 million
dollars
what's the original factory price this
on the bracelet right here we had it for
600
wow so it went from 600 to over a
million well that's for his
personal i get it but it's the same
piece but it does have some
really interesting you know backstory to
it it also has a high frequency cord so
traditional quartz is going to oscillate
like 32 000 times per second
that's like 262 000 yeah that's a very
attractive piece at a great price
i mean i think what's good about this is
you're really opening my eyes up to
some very interesting price points here
so that's getting in so
about 600 bucks there now once you go to
our next fades up okay
some other stuff that you might think is
cool
this one is not probably the thing
that's going to epitomize the brand
but it's got some cool backstory so this
is called the ventura from hamilton so
this is i'm well aware of that that's a
very famous style
very famous you know every everybody
that's into watches knows this piece in
terms of the shape of that
yes and it was really became popular i
mean it was unveiled in 1957 but
uh elvis actually wore it famously so
it's kind of been claimed as the
theology and so did the jetsons it does
look like a futuristic 1950s
you know exactly absolutely that but if
you look towards the future this is i
think what people were
the price point 840 bucks incredible of
course can you get it today for that
price yes
yeah we sell it um it's a pretty cool
launch that's beautiful
very very cool did elvis have this
little waveform on it too
so the story behind it it was actually
the first watch with a battery
and they had this weird setup where it
was using magnets and then it had a
traditional balance wheel
so and that's how that watch would work
a lot of them didn't function very
properly
that sounds like a horrific design so
they transitioned over to
quartz which that one's gonna be a
quartz watch but you know high accuracy
this one i thought would be interesting
because you're from canada yeah
right yeah this is a canadian brand
you're kidding marathon so marathon
made in canada so they make their
watches in switzerland yeah they were
founded in canada yeah they got the rise
in 19
really became very popularized in this
military-style watch that you're seeing
here in 1941 because it supplied watches
for the allied forces
both for canadian and american armed
forces and
all their watches are really built for
that spec so this is called the
government search and rescue and they're
still being used by military personnel
to this day
use tritium it's a dive watch it's a
tool watch what i have found a lot of
collectors who
really tell me the price again that's
gonna be twelve hundred dollars wow
that's a great value and a very striking
piece i mean
this is a honking piece of metal it is
honking and it looks
so you see how it's like seated very low
in the dial like the dial seems seated
very low yeah that's done with intention
so what that watch uses is tritium
so tritium is different than what you'll
probably see on most of these watches
that use super luminous
luminova tritium is a constant
illuminating
illuminating material so i have actual
gas tubes inside there
that's going to house that tritium and
why people in the armed forces like this
is because it's constantly illuminating
it doesn't need to be charged so when
you're in very dark environments
it's going to of course never fail you
fantastic so like really deep underwater
yes very deep underwater and the reason
they have to make it so
kind of like they step the dial in a way
and have it seated so low and if drivers
adopted this
yes absolutely amazing price point yes
so i thought that'd be interesting
because you had that connection to
canada all right
another place to look i love this brand
yeah
it's called so jung hans is kind of
classic
germany it almost looks swatch-like you
know it does have a little bit of that
so it's mid
50 you know 1950s there was a swiss
designer max bill
yeah a very famous architect who went to
the baja school of design i am a huge
fan of i could see the elements of baja
in there
for sure this was a watch that not this
specific one
but max bill he was went from creating
wall clocks first
for the brand and then transitioned into
wrist watches that's nice
price point 1300 bucks not bad not bad
that is actually very unique as a dial
it is there's really beautiful people
there's really nothing else like that so
when people are looking for that
they call it minimalism but i i there's
minimalism as a pursuit something like a
lovato kind of thing you know
a little bit of that but i mean this is
true bauhaus design
true principles from that school from an
iconic designer i like it
tell me about let me pick some dials
here yes no actually please tell me
about this one this is also very
interesting
so one of my favorite brands and i will
i don't want to say his name but
last time that we had dinner in miami we
were sitting with a man in the industry
that was i think we both
hold in high regard i asked him what
brands
do you respect he said brands like rolex
paddock
of course you know another brand he
mentioned this one right here what is it
no one's glassing so they're a new
german brand you're kidding
1990 they started wow right after the
you know the fall of the berlin wall you
know they emerged very much like other
brands in germany at that time
but they're doing some fantastic things
so this is a in-house caliber
you're looking at 3 700 bucks for this
yeah very much
a lot of the same type of inspirations
as 3 700
you're kidding now a brand like this are
you gonna buy this direct from the
online from the company yeah we sell it
as well um and the cool thing about this
one what's going on here with this so
this is fun all right so this is their
metro it's called and this is a power
reserve so what they've done is there's
a little aperture in the dial
and it will actually have three discs
with gears on it
so as you rotate see what's happening
there see that little red it's slowly
disappearing so what that's doing is
it's indicating to me once that red
disappears
that this thing is fully wound so it's
just oh so it's a power reserve
indicator yeah it's
really a very great idea it's very cool
that is cool
they're making their own movements this
also they're actually making their own
escapements as well
yeah there's that's amazing for around
three three grand so east berlin type
thing where this goes yeah so they're in
glacier they're in glacier time okay
very interesting that's the same yes
same city tell me the price again
37.80 yeah amazing that's fantastic so
okay
launch maker real watch that is that you
know that's that's very interesting
let me pick one more then i'm going to
show you some yeah please okay looking
for something
you know tiso is always a classic
starter
watch it is i i forgot to mention tco at
the beginning so that's the new prx
and that has been very popular as of
late
it you probably can guess why i mean you
can see the inspiration being drawn from
that integrated steel sport
style bracelet price point what would
you guess
1200 what if i told you 375 bucks wow
that's a phenomenal deal with a brand
that's well known in europe
yes maybe not as much here but you know
you go to switzerland walk around geneva
everybody knows it too so
oh 100 yeah cool i mean case finishing
yeah i think it's way above what it's
fun it's almost grand seiko-ish and
polish
uh it's beautifully done it's very nice
for that price these are incredible
deals it's a great idea teddy to cover
it this way absolutely great yeah
because i think everybody like you said
they deserve to own a nice watch i
really think it should be limiting
because i guarantee somebody's buying
that watch today is coming
in here and buying a rolex you know or
you know whatever they're gonna i
understand but let's let's talk okay
let's
all right let's get let's go to an
entry-level watch right here
this is a um rainbow
from rolex i'm sorry i'm just kidding no
i know but i mean you know it's it's a
beautiful piece it's very unique
a lot of work goes into actually getting
this this four degree
separation of the rainbow itself with
these jewels
now it's not exactly enteral entry-level
pricing it's about a hundred and fifty
thousand but they're tr because they're
very hard to find they traded about four
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
a good way to start now you can either
send your whole family to college buy a
house or get this watch
i'm just having something they're going
to a good school today no i know i'm
just having something
but i buy a watch like this because it's
very collectible as an investment
obviously that appreciation from
retail to the current prices it's rarity
and i'll do one more fun one just
because it's fun to show off a little
bit
i have the tiger a great entry level
diamond piece that's like looking into
the sun i know you can't really tell the
time you need sunglasses but
it's i didn't used to do bling since i
last saw you i was
very much against playing but i've been
turned on to because i'm living in miami
now i need some
really trashy stuff that's and this is
this is it i mean this really looks
ridiculous that is going to catch the
eye i can imagine that on the beach or
taking a walk
that just gets a little this with jeans
on and a t-shirt that's the look i'm
looking for here
but also you know a ridiculous price
however
it doesn't mean that that's all i buy
i'm a collector so let me show you
something
i think you can appreciate this i love
this you tell me what this is
long gene conquest yeah what do you
think the price is
well i know it's around a grand it's
about 1200 bucks probably yeah
i am so so i'd buy dials and i don't
really care what the price is
including going down to something you
know under two thousand or a thousand
dollars
this style is stunning it's a beautiful
piece and it reminds me very much of
this style
you know the 60th anniversary version
they call it the superman
also very affordable very affordable but
you can see
similarities in terms of look and feel
of that can't you
this is around six thousand dollars but
these are some of the watches i wear
every day because i just appreciate the
beauty it doesn't mean everything i've
got
has to be a ridiculous price now here's
something i don't think you've seen
ever because there are none tell me
about this watch this you know the brand
you know the look and feel this is the
pilot iwc
right um i think there's a total
of i can't remember i think it's 1100
pieces but they were only
sold to individuals associated one way
another with lebanon so they were sold
in the united arab emirates and the
boutique in
in beirut to offset the cost of that
horrible
disaster when the boat blew up in beirut
now my mother was lebanese my father was
irish and i was very fortunate to know
one of the
members of the royal family of uae and i
asked on his behalf because he knew my
family
could they approach iwc and allocate one
to america
they actually said no they couldn't but
they would arrange for me to get one
through
my friend so this is only a six thousand
dollar watch
but one of a kind in the lebanese logo
of the cedar of lebanon on the back i
wear this all the time
it reminds me of lebanon and my mother
but you have to say that's a beautiful
piece
stunning i love the green it's fantastic
the green is it's green black depending
on the light so
again a piece in my collection that is
not a crazy price
but i'm looking for something unique as
a collector and this certainly fits into
that category
so what i'm saying is you don't have to
buy a huge expensive
collection you can find collectible
watches at very reasonable prices
i also consider this superman this grand
seiko sixth anniversary
to be highly collectible because they
only made a certain number of them and i
think in the years ahead this will
appreciate in value and look terrific
so that was the theme oh teddy one other
watch here
um this one hurts a little bit yes it
should if you watched our previous video
you
came over from teddy's video i'm going
to do the 57 super ocean
and i'm going to do the ball when you're
not compliant you have to be punished
teddy and now that's going to happen
right here my friend yeah i want to make
it painful you saw that teddy broke the
rules in our contest
and his punishment was to let me buy
this watch which i did for 35 i was
given incorrect information
stars and stripes and i know you know
this mark tell us about this brand
i mean in some way you can kiss a
goodbye by explaining what it is so
bolova is a great rich history brand
here in america founded by joseph bulova
he was an american immigrant
and they were really trailblazers in
adopting a lot of interesting styles and
also just ways and methods of marketing
products during the
mid 20th century they were the first
brand to actually uh have the first
tv ad i don't know if you ever knew that
during the world series i do remember i
do remember so they did that they were
also very
active in tv you know sponsoring frank
sinatra
and then once you got to the 1970s like
this piece they start getting into these
crazy chronographs they're just very
eccentric and fun
this this is really they call it the
stars and stripes because it emulates an
american flag
kind of got like these hands that look
like rockets it's it's fun it's a lot of
fun and i think it's going to look
terrific
on my wrist and i love the fact that now
i'm investing in vintage i don't do a
lot of that but when you get something
so unique
plus i can take it out of your
collection into mine which makes it
extra special
that makes it a story watch and a little
painful for you i realized but for me
it's
absolutely wonderful i will tell the
story to everybody that doesn't see this
video
if you see you know teddy broke the
rules very bad boy
and i got this watch as a result it's
absolutely spectacular
thank you teddy look i've had a
wonderful the woman
listen the pain will eventually go away
as you see me wear this all over the
place
it's fine but i really love it and thank
you very much for bringing it up and
showing it to me it was actually great
of course anyways thank you so much
you're such a
knowledge of of what your what your
knowledge to watch this makes it really
interesting because
i think what you did today was important
i spent so much time talking about the
crazy
prices on watches which i've been
appreciating as an asset class
very well but it it makes it you have to
take time to go back and look at what's
available
at any price and you've brought forward
some amazing pieces at incredible prices
that have really opened my eyes up to
maybe
look there's a lot to be done at under a
thousand dollars in fact you know under
500
fantastic watches yeah there's a lot to
have i mean there's other great brands
on here too like an aorus for example
which is fantastic that two thousand
dollar range
zen lotto micro brands like a formax and
monta i mean it's beautiful it's a lot
there's a lot out there
so you don't need a ton of money you
don't need a ton of money to actually
get into collecting watches that's the
key
think about that you can start at a very
low price point diversity of dial
diversity so everything's different in
your collection that's wonderful
look for things that don't look like the
other watches you have and
build a collection as i love to call it
teddy thank you so much
great working with you today i look
forward to our next journey wherever it
takes us
see where it goes as always